hello everyone and welcome to today's
panel discussion
adapting to succeed perspectives
from leaders in industry and academia
using flow cytometry for covid19
research
i'm susie valdez lab roots and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's discussion is presented by
labyrinth and brought to you by sony
biotechnology
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit their website
at www.sony
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions
as you want at any time you want during
the discussion
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and press send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the support tab found at
the top right
of your presentation window or report
your problem
by clicking on the ask question box
so let's get started as you know
the kobit 19 pandemic has influenced
us all in many ways the scientific
community has really shown
resolve to continue their work in the
reality of this pandemic
researchers around the world have come
together to design
anti-viral vaccines develop diagnostic
tests
and set up testing facilities in their
labs
they have found creative ways of
donating their time expertise and
supplies to accelerate
the research and aid preparedness during
this time
today we will be discussing with leaders
from the industry
and academia how they have adapted to
speed and contribute
to covid19 research joining us on our
panel today
are dr frederick laduke who is the ceo
and co-founder of immune biosolutions a
biotech
company focusing on the discovery and
engineering
of next generation biologists
dr baduk holds a phd from the university
of shearbrook
and has a background in biochemistry
biotechnology
and exotoxicology our second panelist is
patricia rogers
who is an associate director of the flow
cytometry core facility
at broad institute of mit and harvard
patricia is founded and has been leading
the flow core for
the past five years where they support
about 300 users
and over 20 research instruments
including flow totometers
cell disorders and molecular biology
instrumentation
patricia has a background in
microbiology and cell biology
and has been in the field of flow
cytometry for the
past 15 years and welcome to our third
panelist
who is dr jeff milish who is an
associate
professor of medicine at the university
of california san francisco
and the director of the directs the uss
core immunology laboratory that provides
support for sample processing
and immunologic assays required in basic
and translational research projects dr
malush
holds a phd from the university of
texas southwestern medical center and
has a background in molecular
microbiology
fred patricia and jeff welcome to this
session
so let's begin this first question is
for all of the panelists
we'll start with you patricia tell us
how you and your team are doing and what
the current status of your research or
biotech facilities
being open hi susie thanks for the
question
and also for lab roots of having me as a
panelist today
to start as susie mentioned i run a
large shared instrumentation facility
or core facility at the broad institute
we're a group of seven
so there's two flow techs to staff
scientists to admin and myself and we
have a plethora of instruments
um and we're all we're all doing well
we're managing everything the best we
can right now
um and what we primarily do is we mostly
train researchers or offer consultations
but we also do
offer some staff run services and
you know there really were three phases
of us being opened over the past few
months and so when i think back to early
march
really the first week of march the broad
held a town hall to have a discussion
around coronavirus
i remember one of our core institute
members highlighted the need to be
concerned
but not overly worried a week later all
of our admin and data scientists were
sent home to begin remote work
our two admins in our group transitioned
that week to supporting us remotely
at that time the rest of us left in the
lab wondered how safe was it to be
working in a poor facility
core facilities are by their nature hubs
of connectivity and activity
and we can have up to 30 people in the
lab at one time working
so that was kind of a little worrisome
to all of us
and then that second week of march the
three remaining staff and i started
working impaired shifts in the lab
the routine transitioned to staff and i
working alternating days
and then during those days we would do a
lot of cleaning so cleaning high touch
spots in the lab with bleach or hydrogen
peroxide wipes
and stocking the lab with supplies
because we weren't really sure are we
going to be
able to come back the next day you know
are we going to be all healthy
so so we were really just trying to
repair the lab in case we had to shut
down
and it really felt like this mad dash in
the facility because researchers were
trying to wind down experiments
because we all knew it was coming and we
were trying to determine which
instruments should be left on
and which others should be put in
storage so the third week is when we
really got the the notice that hey we
were winding down
everyone wrapped things up that isn't
critical and at this
at that time i felt it was really
important for my stuff to start staying
home at this week and so i continued to
come into the lab that week and i
started putting
the really large sorters that were staff
run only into storage
mode and then i was trying to figure out
which instrument should i leave on for
the researchers
to continue the critical research
lucky for us about 99 of our researchers
are trained to run the instruments
themselves
and most of the instrumentation our
facility is easy to use and quite robust
this was key for allowing research to
continue without having to be physically
on-site in order to keep the density low
at the institute
i also made sure to leave detailed notes
around the lab for where extra supplies
might be or how best to take care of
things to avoid problems
for the next few months we transitioned
to working at home as a team and
supporting the researchers who were
doing the same
by hosting webinars or assisting with
data analysis
i was mainly helping the onsite
researchers by no donating whatever we
had in the facility that could be used
to help with covered research
just little things like centrifuges or
reagents
and actually one of the impressive
achievements of the institute was to
turn our clia certified genomics lab
into a cova 19 testing facility for the
state of massachusetts
we are now able to run up to 35 000 past
a day for the state with a turnaround
time of only a day
and then the last phase has really been
to return to broad
so on june 1st we started our ramp up
just two of us and my team returned that
initial week to turn the instruments
back on
and to get the lab ready for the
researchers who are returning on june
7th
and again i've split my lab my group up
into two
shifts so we basically span the full day
of 8 a.m to 8 p.m
working into two groups because i can
only have about six people in my lab at
a time
and this means um all scheduling needs
to be centralized to one person
and we have to learn that how many
instruments are used at one time
every day before we enter the building
we have to answer a health questionnaire
and everyone is required to wear a face
mask at all times
there's typically about two to three
hundred lab workers at the institute at
once and most of us are working limited
hour shifts and this is really to you
know prevent
you know people from congregating in the
institute or having to eat lunch here
um we're really only supposed to come on
to get our work done and then to go
back home and we're still cleaning
everything so that's a big part
of what we do every day is we come in
and we clean everything
before doing quality control in all the
instruments
and we've also had to move some
instruments out into new locations
but the the main key it's like you know
we're we're all working together
to to stay healthy and
maintaining our social distance of six
feet apart and
and that's been working so far for us
thank you so much patricia and how about
you jeff
how is your team doing what is the
current status of your research
and your facilities
yeah thank you for having me on today uh
telling you a little bit about what
we've been doing
um so my team and and i are doing well
overall
uh it's really hard to believe that
we're already in mid-july and that
this all started back in about mid-march
um
but you know i have to really commend
the team on
on the great job that they've been doing
um it's not that
often that we get to talk about our team
and and the work that they do and how
they
how they support all these various
researchers but they've really done a
fantastic job of
of adapting to the ever-changing demands
and schedules that
were needed to accommodate the studies
we
basically began pivoting um in mid-march
to doing
uh copiou related research and we had to
shut down
about 20 or so 25 active studies that
were recruiting
um patients and sending us specimens or
that we were
performing assays on and we really had
to shut all that down and transition
over to the covid research
and in addition to kind of changing
the uh the types of studies that we were
working with and sort of the
the types of biohazards that we were
dealing with
there was just this increased stress of
not really knowing what was happening on
a day-to-day basis at the beginning
and trying to adapt to the new biosafety
conditions that we had to work in
figuring out how
just to commute between your home and
work safely
and all of this was kind of being done
as i said in the process of ramping down
the ongoing studies and then increasing
um
workloads on the copic side of things
and that
in order to really meet those demands of
the the kobit research we had to shift
our hours and
you know it was very impressive the the
staff were all very willing
to change from their normal sort of nine
to five-ish
job schedules to basically running seven
days a week at the beginning
and at times that meant coming in as
early as
6 30 in the morning and staying open as
late as seven o'clock
or so at night um in order to
accommodate all the the specimens that
were coming in from the hospital
but i really have to commend the team on
on their willingness to adapt to this
and and their ability to
to stay focused on these tasks and
provide
our highest quality service that you
know our investigators have come to know
us for
um and and that's not easy given all the
changes that were going on
you know in particular my lab manager
norm did a fantastic job
he had the the responsibility of combing
through all these studies that were
coming in
uh making sure that the protocols um
were
in a format that the lab could read
through
digest down and be able to perform the
assays and the processing
that the studies needed we had to make
sure that you know basic
supplies we could get our hands on in
order to process the sample safely
including
ppe which um at the beginning was was
definitely
difficult to get our hands on um and
then my processing team lead
christina she really did a great job of
holding down the fort
um her and and the four people that um
work with her
on specimen processing they needed to
change their shifts they needed to start
early they needed to work weekends
and they did this um incredibly well um
they were always very dependable and
they just
never miss a beat and cranking out high
quality samples
um which was really nice to see and uh
our admin staff they were they were kind
of forced into
um you know city mandates of having
people that were not lab uh oriented
had to work off campus and so meredith
and val had to start working
very early on um from home
in about mid-march and you know this
this puts a strain on things
our team is very close-knit we work
together well um we're used to
interacting on a
face-to-face basis and in order to get
the work done
and so there was a there was a learning
curve but they
really did a great job of also staying
engaged and and helping
the team remotely and sometimes
you know the the best examples of
some of their help probably comes in in
the form of just providing
snacks and organizing or what we call
socially distanced
lunches for the team to try to bring in
some food because it wasn't always that
easy to go out and
and pick up your lunch at the
restaurants around here
and so you know it was kind of a little
team pick me up and and everybody got a
chance
to um you know take a break and and
have a have a nice lunch and couldn't
necessarily do it all together but you
know it was
it was nice to at least be able to give
give the team members a chance to enjoy
something special
um while they're you know changing their
lifestyle up in order to accommodate
these studies
and then you know balan and meredith
also had
the important responsibilities of
keeping things running behind the scenes
and keeping our databases going and
continuing to run the reports and
analyzing data as we were
acquiring it for the investigators but
you know
overall i think we were fortunate we
never had to shut down the lab
and it was really a great opportunity
for us to help with
many different studies we're involved in
nine or so studies at this point
um and it's it's been fun and
challenging to work with
all the different investigators now that
um we're into july most things have
opened back up at some level limited
capacity here at ucsf
um and so even though many of the cores
did shut down to various extents
most of them have begun to reopen as of
mid-may
and are running at various various
levels of
capacity right now i think the main
thing is we're still trying to maintain
social distancing and things like that
to keep
employees safe and and keep the
operations going but also to be able to
support
uh the work that's that needs to be
done for not only the covet side but now
trying to
restart those studies that had to be put
on paused and
and that's really kind of our next big
challenge now is how we
overlay the studies that were ongoing uh
before the shelter in place took effect
with
the studies that are now um
coming in quite rapidly with many
samples unfortunately
due to the increasing number of
infected and hospitalized people but
you know that's that's sort of the next
challenge we'll see how how that goes
but
you know working with the investigators
now to try to
basically get their studies back up and
running but at the same time
uh make sure that they that we set
realistic uh expectations with them in
order to
um you know provide everybody with a
with top quality service
regardless of whether it's covet or not
so
thank you jeff for sharing that
information and fred how about you
how is your team doing and tell us a
little bit about the current status of
your research and biotech
facility yeah so
um just to give you give the audience a
little bit of background so our company
is located in small university town
called sherbrooke in the province of
quebec
in canada so we're about four hours away
from a far worse drive away from boston
up north very close to the american
border we were
actually hit hard uh by by this pandemic
pretty much the same time as new york
was uh mainly because we have
uh the equivalent of a spring break in
early march
so a lot of uh of our population
traveled
to the us to europe to caribbeans
and brought back more than just
souvenirs so
the province quebec was was hit hard
but the government on provincial
level but also in federal gov state um
decided to take immediate measures
uh so we we've been able to sort of
flatten the curve and
so our position was we we weren't very
strong crisis at the beginning but uh we
managed to uh
sort of uh go through it uh it's never
perfect as you all know but
uh definitely was uh it was a
we were lucky in that sense um very
early on
uh we were fortunate that our uh our
government
understood that live life science
companies uh should be kept open
um so we were considered an essential
services
mainly because we were driving new
diagnostics
helping hospitals with with diagnostic
tried to
either design new vaccines or new
therapeutics
so definitely our sector has been very
active
although um it was a it was a challenge
to stay open
um so and and in in a sense if there's a
sector that could
stay open uh while uh well
while there's that kind of pandemic it's
definitely the life science sector where
we
understand the risk we can implement uh
procedures and then so on measures that
would
limit the the infection
so very early on in march we decided to
put every scientist that we could uh
working from home and we were fortunate
in terms of facilities
our labs are basically a bunch of small
labs
one next to the other so basically we
limited
the number of two to one scientists per
lab
so we were able to sort of keep the work
going uh
start our programs of discovery for
corvin 19
and pretty much managed to stay uh at
100 capacity i would actually say that
we were more at 120 or 130
percent of our capacity definitely very
motivated
in finding new solutions interacting
with the ecosystem with the community
from locally and internationally to sort
of
bring what we could to help
hospitals and to do collaboration that
would have an impact
as soon as possible so really
i think it was a really bad situation
but
at the same time we saw the community
just
[Music]
rise to the occasion so definitely it
was a difficult situation and
i heard patricia and jeff tell a little
bit
how they did it uh we did very similar
things uh
but at the same time we we were part of
this uh
we are still part of that race to find a
therapeutic uh
something that would uh protect uh the
people so
we're still very active in that space
patricia jeff this next question is for
you describe for the audience
how your institution and your team
had to pivot to respond to the emerging
needs to support
covenanting research and what measures
did your facility implement to minimize
individual risk while handling
covid19 infected specimens and patricia
we'll start with you
um so in late april i started to get
requests to sort samples from recovered
patients of copin 19
mainly whole blood from the boston area
and while the risk is quite low for this
type of sample we still
don't know the full story so i reached
out to my ehs
director we had a discussion and decided
that it was best to treat these samples
with additional caution
they you know these patients had
recovered they no longer had covid but
you know we still weren't sure what to
do
so it's not quite a bl3 but something
like a bl2 plus
so we determined the best course of
action was to limit the number of people
who have exposure to these samples by
isolating one sales order in its own
room
and you know my room is one giant room
so i
i had to figure out how do i get one of
the south orders out
while social distancing and move it to
another room across the institute
while social distancing so it took a lot
of teams including space planning and
facilities ehs and also sony
we had coordinated to move a sony ma900
plus his biosafety cabinet out of the
main floor facility into a small room
across the hall
so this room had some nice features that
had car ad access
so i could limit who was in there and
also enough space so i could put some
smaller equipment like centrifuges for
spinning down plates both sorting
and then you know i already had it in
our calendar system but i took it away
so people couldn't access it anymore and
only gave it
access to people who needed to sort
these types of samples
and also i had to think about in general
anyone now working with unfixed human
samples
we needed to move their samples over to
this room
and in april it was really just the
samples coming from recovered
coven 19 patients because all other
science wasn't going on at that time
and because of you know the nature of
self-worthing you really want to isolate
these samples in its own room because so
if anything happens
you can contain it much easier
and you don't have as many people around
like if i had this
you know these samples coming into the
main room i could have you know
six to other people in there that could
be potentially exposed to them
but we're also handling covid positive
samples at the road
but in the bl3 facility which is not
really in my jurisdiction
so we had to come up with a plan and
we're working on it right now
because there are going to be more
requests to bring human samples
back to the institute from the hospitals
nearby and we have to decide when the
samples come into the institute what the
safety level
of them are and then what appropriate
facilities should they go to for
processing
so if it's infected samples or
post-mortem samples they should go to
bl3
and if they're recovered patient samples
they can come over to the bl2
and also if their donor sample is coming
from the hospital
and they've been screened and they can
come into the main facility
under normal bl2 practices but if
they're coming from the hospitals and
they're not screened then they need to
go into our blt
plus room that has a single sorter in it
and some of the things that we've been
asking researchers to do is either to
have
their samples the people that they're
getting the samples for
tested for covid or if they can't if
that's not possible then doing ptr tests
on their samples to confirm that they're
covered negative
but all of this is you know a
synchronization between all of the
groups and ehs
and my group at fab road to make sure
that
you know we're keeping track of all the
samples that are coming in and that
we're making sure that they're going to
the appropriate areas in order to get
processed
thank you so much patricia and how about
you jeff what measures
are your facilities doing to implement
and minimize individualized
risk and how are you pivoting around the
need for
supporting cobia 19 research
yeah this is a good question and
something that
we have to take very seriously in order
to keep the lab running and our
team safe um so when we went into the
shelter in place
in on march 16 um this really changed
our operations
one it meant that we had to shut down
all our non-essential work
um which was basically anything that
wasn't sarco v2
or or kovid related and second it really
fragmented our team and
you know leading up to this um we were
aware that the shelter in place could be
coming at any point
i think it got accelerated a little bit
quicker than we had thought but we
as soon as we sort of saw the writing on
the wall we began to
prepare ourselves on that some of the
team would have to work off-site
and we started preparing them with the
tools that they would need to
to be able to continue that work at home
which in most cases was making sure that
um that the team had access to computers
and computer screens
and so we sort of took care of our our
people that we could have work remotely
from home hopefully they would be able
to stay at home and and isolate there
and
and be safe and at the same time
there were plans here on campus put in
place
to begin health screenings for all staff
that were basically entering the campus
and we began to wear masks all day long
while we were on campus
and so basically over time there's been
some
changes here and there but basically our
our administrative team
still continues to work remotely and
anyone that is coming onto campus has to
be
go through a health screening so it's a
centralized screening and then
you're given a mass to wear if you don't
already have one i mean you have to keep
that on while you're working at all
times
within the lab we've taken additional
precautions
and so you know part of what we want to
do is maintain
a low occupancy level on on campus in
general and so
we're only at about 25 percent of our
working capacity on the campus
and so you know just the number of
people on this campus has been
trimmed down in order to keep space
between people
and then in the lab we can accomplish
this because we have multiple
sort of satellite rooms and so the team
can split up and work in different
biosafety cabinets without having to be
right on top of one another
and this has really allowed us to keep a
a almost a full team in the lab at all
times in order to
keep up with the work but inside the lab
everybody is continuing to wear face
masks
and then we also require everybody to
wash their hands as soon as they walk
into the lab
just cutting down on any you know
potential foam light transmissions
and then we on a daily basis
actually multiple times a day high touch
areas in the lab were sprayed down with
70
ethanol and and kind of kept clean so
that um
any again any exposures can be minimized
um and then like i said we we set up
these smaller rooms
um for handling source code v2 infected
specimens
so for us uh anything that is suspected
to be sars cov2
positive uh in terms of blood samples
has to be worked with in a bsl2 room
and in there our lab staff have
our normal liquid impermeable lab coats
and safety glasses
but we also require them to wear double
gloves and
within the room anything that is
you know any of the equipment that
touches these samples we decontaminate
to the best of our ability so it's
either spraying it down with 70 percent
ethanol
or 10 bleach and then we also
soak our our centrifuge buckets and
things like that in order to
um remove any uh potential
uh contaminants and may have gotten on
that uh so
there's definitely a lot more cleaning
that's happening inside the
the rooms and inside the lab in general
and then for samples that are coming in
that are
from the trachea so for those
patients who are on ventilators uh we
worked with our
building engineers and our environmental
health and safety group
to basically repurpose a small room that
we had with two biosafety cabinets in it
um so that that room was under a
negative pressure and this is
considered our bsl2 star room and so
like i said we in there we're allowed to
handle tracheal aspirates
and um not only is the room under
negative pressure but we have also
um have some increased uh ppe that we
wear in there so
um here we're wearing back uh back
closed gowns instead of the front closed
gowns
we double glove and we're sleep
protectors along with our normal eye
protection
but probably the biggest thing is that
we also are wearing n95 masks when we
work in that room
in order to cut down any potential um
aerosolization
that may happen um and again everything
is
is continued to be wiped down with
ethanol and with um
with a 10 bleach solution
and soaked in 10 bleach if we can for
things like
centrifuge buckets um so that's that's
kind of what we're doing
in the lab when we're handling specimens
we um for the most part right now are
not
dealing with cell sorting of highly
infectious
samples most of our our sorting has been
being done
by magnetic isolation and so
that is a lot safer for us right now we
can do that inside of a biosafety
cabinet without much
aerosolization concerns and so
it's allowed us to continue to work with
samples in rich subsets and then do
single cell genomics assays with those
samples
on our cytometers though right now we're
requiring people to
fix all of their specimens whether or
not they're
copied positive or not in one percent
pair formaldehyde
and in order to inactivate any of the
pathogens
and then we have a bsl2 cytometry room
that has
um two instruments in it and those
instruments right now can only be booked
one at a time to
again cut down on the number of
personnel in the room um
and then we have a a cell sorter
that's in our bsl two-star room in an
adjacent building
and in there since that's inside of a
biosafety cabinet
folks if they want to sort
blood specimens from infected
individuals
that would need to be done in the bsl2
star with an n95 mask
that sorter is in its own wing of the
bsl2 star
and so um it's it's physically distanced
from other
folks working in there and it's also
inside the hood
to cut down on any potential
contamination
for more infectious samples like lung
or tracheal aspirates those would
require for us to be sorted in a bsl3
and there we have a ma900 that's in a
biosafety cabinet and in order to do
sorts like that that would need to be
coordinated with some other labs that
that work in that
bsl3 but in there uh individuals would
have to wear full papers
and we probably would be running those
sorts for the individuals
and for those investigators rather than
having them
access that bsl-3 since there's uh
additional training that would require
but full packers are in there so
hopefully that
on top of being inside about a safety
cabinet um
you know will cut down on any potential
risks that
that are occurring i think you know the
the big takeaway from this is that we
are
we are trying to keep our social
distancing in the lab wearing face masks
all the time and trying to clean
surfaces
to cut down on any potential
transmission that may occur
so
thank you jeff now let's move to the
discussion of research studies
patricia we'll start with you what type
of studies are being supported by your
core labs and how do
the researchers use flow cytometry for
cubic 19 research
so there are many copin 19 projects
ongoing at broad and one way we are
helping
in the fluorescein facility is by
facilitating cell sorting of immune
populations
so we enable researchers by training
them on the sony sales orders
so they can purify or enrich populations
for mainly single cell genomics work
because
that's a lot of what we do abroad is
genomics
the most popular applications include
bulk enrichment for 10 extronomics
library construction
or sorting single cells directly into
micro well plates for library
construction
for applications like smart c2 before
going on to sequencing
there are other applications that we use
flow cytometry for
not just porting we also do analysis so
we do a lot of crispr analysis looking
at fluorescent protein expression
and one example is the team uproad have
been working on an interesting area
to explore how to do more cova testing
and so the zhang lab for example has led
efforts to create a rapid coven 19 test
using crispr based technologies
and it's called sherlock and that will
help to create some more diagnostic
tools that
people will be able to use at home so
these are just a few applications of
what we're doing in the flow cytometry
and facility and a lot of what we do is
we just train people to do this
themselves
and so we haven't been training people
lately um because we have to keep our
social distancing so we're trying to
figure out that next step and how to do
remote training for everyone
but everyone that's already been trained
uh before pandemic has been
in the lab and using the instruments for
these types of applications
thank you patricia and jeff how about
you tell us a little bit about the
studies being supported by your core lab
okay so our core lab is a little bit
different we're
um we're a full wet lab so basically
what i mean by that is that we are
helping individuals everywhere from
processing specimens
cryopreserving them we run assays for
the studies and so we're we're seeing
examples
um straight from the the clinics that
arrive
within 10 minutes of being drawn from
patients
to those samples that are being shipped
in from outside locations
for processing and assay work i would
say our
our studies break down into kind of four
major categories
two of those are on the therapeutic side
where we're supporting studies looking
at
repurposed drugs like rem dempsevier
or canakinumab or the other side of the
therapeutics is looking at kind of
cellular and immune modulatory drugs
so there's one group that we were
working with that was doing
mesenchymal stem cell
infusions to see if those stem cells
could
help alleviate some of the ards
symptoms in in the severely ill
patients and then the canakinumab
um i'm sorry the
convalescent serum that's being infused
in some patients we're collecting
samples from them
to look at at what is happening with
their viral loads and their disease
progression and then we have some basic
science
studies where we're just looking at host
immune responses
and so there's there are studies with
different cohorts
um where we are collecting blood
uh blood specimens urine saliva
feces there's many different tissues i
think everybody's trying to collect as
many
varied specimens as they possibly can
some of those are being used right away
by different investigators and we need
to get those shipped out
to those labs others are just being
banked for down
downstream applications and for studies
that haven't necessarily
come to light yet but there's
um on our side with those studies we're
doing everything from the specimen
processing and shipping out
to also helping uh run cytop assays on
these samples
um or running single cell genomics uh
studies so these are cases where we're
taking
uh like tracheal aspirates and enriching
for cd45 positive
immune cells out of those tracheal
aspirates and then performing
single cell genomics assays on them to
look at
transcriptional profiles of immune cells
that are coming from these
patients who are on ventilators
and then we also have some studies that
are just doing
uh antigen specific t cell responses
and looking at the immunophenotype of
the of the
cells that are in these patients with
different degrees of
disease progression and looking at their
antigen specific t cell responses to the
sars cov2
virus i think you know trying to
understand the difference between
the serology and the and the antigen
specific t cell responses is going to be
important
uh these systems work together closely
and um
and understanding both arms of that
adaptive immune response is going to be
important
and then lastly we have one study that's
kind of more focused on viral shedding
it has immune components to it as well
but we're in that study it's really
focused
on how long individuals shed infectious
virus
and so we're collecting lots of
different specimen types there
again running some cytoph and doing some
sars cov2 viral loads in the lab to
understand
how much virus is in the different
locations within the body and
for how long you can isolate infectious
virus from those
locations to sort of
help with decisions of how long some
somebody would need to
isolate themselves before they were not
infectious
to family members or the community so
it's
a pretty broad array of studies that
we're supporting and those are just
studies that
that my group is specifically supporting
there are certainly
many others that are happening across
the sf campus
and collaborations between both other
academic institutions
and industry partners as well which i
think is
is really important in driving
both vaccines and potential new
therapeutics for those folks who are
infected or to prevent new infections
thank you jeff for sharing now fred this
next question
is for you tell us about the technology
offered by your company immune
biosolutions
and how it works
yeah so um as i mentioned our facilities
uh we do have a couple of interesting
platforms
but i think the um we're quite well
known
for hacking the immune system of
chickens
this is really an amazing amazing
species to work with
definitely an interesting immune system
and actually we do know
quite a lot about this immune system
actually b cells
the b stands for bursa which is an organ
only found in birds
so definitely there's a history on of
knowledge
on this immune system so what we do is
we try to
take advantage of this unique immune
system that
derives quite a lot of diversity in
terms of antibodies very quickly
uh in the case of cova 19 definitely we
were looking at this so
we we have several platforms that we're
using
uh to generate our antibody candidates
from uh target evaluation antigen design
up to biomanufacturing so different
parts of these of these platforms were
used for
to drive these programs so we have
a platform that is using
bioinformatics in civil code design to
generate 3d peptides
so to give the immune system
a synthetic peptide but with a 3d shape
we haven't used that technology for for
covet 19 because we wanted to go
faster and the crystals were not
available uh
early on so we use a very broad spectrum
approach with our with our
with our antigen so like i said we use
mainly
uh the chicken to derive these uh these
libraries
of antibodies we have two platforms to
select the best candidates
um both uh are have advantages uh
this is for sure we have a page display
platform
also a direct
b cell screening approach that will show
in a few slides
and both are are combined with negative
sequencing
and ai algorithms to sort of find the
best candidates
very early on and filter the one the the
sequences of antibodies that might be
problematic for
different reasons immunogenicity for
example manufacturing
uh and and so on and after that
surprisingly
uh chicken antibodies are easy to
humanize once you know
what once you know how they have a very
conserved framework
so once you have the the right amino
acids that you don't want to change
we can derive very early on these
humanized formats
so all this is combined under a roof to
generate
antibody candidates for most of time for
oncology
and and infectious disease
we have a couple programs in oncology
that are a few months away from
from ind and we have a cd program
that is uh in in animal in vivo
validation
so we had quite a lot of experience with
uh with different viruses
different difficult targets and we
definitely applied
all this knowledge to derive very
quickly
programs against sars code too
so i i can tell you tell you about two
things about this program so we
wanted to act quickly to generate the
best candidates
to to start with so we use our chicken
approach for sure
um so we we immunize the animals collect
the b
cells and use our our b cell screening
approach
we also recruited convalescent human
patients and used about the same
approach but
this time with human b cells so this is
a typical essay that we
we do on a platform so these are very
small
uh wells what i would call nanowells
about 2.6 nanoliters
so we can uh put one b cells in each of
these
hundred thousands of nanowells and
in those wells we typically use either a
specificity assay or
functionality assay in the case of the
kovit 19
we didn't have a lot of time to generate
and test these
newly designed functional assay so we
use a specificity assay for
to start with we had two types of beats
as you can see in the screen one type
was recent
these were mtvs that was our negative
control
and we had these bigger beats that were
not going sent
that were conjugated with different uh
proteins from the virus
so we could actually see after a couple
of hours
if our b cells were secreting uh these
very specific antibodies so within
uh again very typical example
uh with the with this uh with this well
after one hour you see a small a small
cloud of red fluorescence and actually
that's a
our secondary antibody that is able to
recognize
the uh the presence of an antibody and
as you can see on the lower panel after
12 after 16 hours
these antibodies are binding to the uh
non-fluorescence
conjugated with with the with the
proteins of the virus
so very rapidly within a few
days we could find these what we call
pre-validated antibodies
they were sequenced all of them several
thousands of these sequences were
of these antibodies were sequenced
analyzed by our ai
algorithms and now we are testing
uh different antibodies with different
assays in vitro and vivo
and combinations as well targeting
different parts of
of the virus and and the spike protein
um
so very very interesting to see how we
could use our platform
to answer very quickly within within a
couple of weeks
uh instead of several years as we uh as
we typically do
in oncology so definitely it's giving us
uh the opportunity to to accelerate
research
and and test our platform to its limit
and was very successful so we're very
happy about our progress
thank you fred and this next question is
for all of the panelists
based on your experience with this new
health
challenge we see what are some of the
key takeaways you can share with our
audience
and patricia we'll start with you
sure so one of the biggest takeaways for
me
of someone who runs a large shared core
facility
is rethinking the nature of how we share
um you know i'm a one large room and i
have a lot of instruments crammed into
this space so i can get
as many people in here and as much stuff
in here for everyone to use
that isn't working out so great now
because we have to be
six feet apart and so i really have to
limit what's getting used at the same
time and
you know usually i i tend to gravitate
towards putting everything that's
similar
together in one area of the lab and now
i'm regretting this decision and
actually what i'm doing right now
is working on restructuring my lab
layout so now i don't have all the same
instruments clustered together
and it will be easier to have all the
instruments used if i enter
first like low used instruments with
more popular instruments
and so that's what that's my next task
for the next few weeks is to basically
rearrange my entire lab which is not
an easy feat and then
also being forced to work remotely
has taught us how to stay connected so
even though we're
apart it seems like we're one team
working together
and you know in the past like jeff had
mentioned earlier that he's a tight-knit
group we're also a very tight-knit group
because it's only seven of us so
we're kind of on top of each other all
the time and just checking in constantly
and having to you know switch gears a
little bit
and try to use new platforms uh more
heavily like slack and google hangouts
has really been instrumental and keeping
us all
informed of what's going on so that way
we can help all the researchers
in the lab and so i think going forward
i'm going to
investigate more and also with my team
to
see what are other platforms and what
other other tools that we can use in
order to stay connected
but yeah those are those are a couple of
my takeaways
thank you patricia and jeff how about
you could you share a little bit about
your experience with disney's
new health challenge we faced
i think um for me there's probably
well there's multiple areas but i think
there's probably three key takeaways
that i
i would want to stress right now one of
those areas is really that
this response to the pandemic has been
has been very positive and it's really
kind of re-emphasized the power of
collaborations in science
and both the collaborations within the
academic institute but also between
academic institutes and industry
partners as well as
um you know even seeing the the
collaborations between
uh potential competitors in the
industry groups it's been really
powerful to see this and
i really hope that that you know going
forward
that everybody sees the benefit of this
and
um you know we can really sustain this
down the road to move science along
quicker and
and bring new therapies and prevention
strategies to um
to the masses basically um i think the
other
area that this has really made me
recognize
um is the importance of of your team and
your family and dealing with these
[Music]
these stressors in these situations like
this we really need to take care of each
other
everybody really needs to um you know
help each other
get through these challenging times and
everybody deals with these
very differently so it's important that
we all check in with our team and
and that's not just your team at work
but your your family
uh team as well just to make sure
everybody's doing well and make sure
that
um you know we're all communicating and
getting the work done in a safe manner
and
and just you know keeping people uh you
know as happy as you can under the
conditions that that we're under
um and then lastly i think uh this is
really similar to what patricia said in
the
um you know thinking about the layout of
the lab we were
really fortunate in this um in this
situation that
our current space we were able to kind
of move things around and reconfigure
quite easily in order to operate with
minimal interactions between groups but
you know thinking about going forward
we're scheduled to move into a new
research building in a few years
and that really has me thinking about
the new space that was designed there
because this the same work that we're
doing right now would not have been
possible in the new um in that new space
and so trying to you know kind of think
how would we deal with this
if this happened two or three years from
now in that new space and how would we
arrange things we can't really change
the architecture at this point for that
new building
so we're going to have to be creative in
other ways to think about how we would
handle
a similar situation i think i can keep
going on about other areas as well but i
think these are
these are some of the important areas
that kind of come to mind right now
thank you jeff and how about you fred
can you provide a
key takeaway to share with our audience
yeah i think i'm gonna add on jeff's
comment i think we've seen
uh an amazing response from the
the scientific community openness
collaboration i've seen
private private sector academia
universities
colleges anyone wanted to
contribute in any matter they could and
that was
awesome that was an amazing time i know
it was a it was a crisis but at the same
time i think we saw
what the community could do when
we all put ourselves together and then
and aim at the same
same goal so that was to me uh really
a great thing and i hope that this
spirit will stay
a little longer and i think we
we saw the potential of working together
uh and definitely for me it's one and
one key positive effect
again to jeff's point uh team
uh is really important we always say
as a company that our team is one of our
is the best asset that we have and
definitely in this
type of crisis we saw what our team
could do
um and it was tremendous we were highly
motivated
everyone understood what was the goal so
it was an amazing time for our team to
just
put the pieces together interact with
collaborators
and partners and to find a solution so
there's a lot of positive things coming
out of this crisis
um there's a there's another good side
for me
uh from this crisis and that's very
there that's very
uh self-centered in some way
i do not have to explain what an
antibody is
uh so that's that's a great thing for me
uh i
i used to spend at least a couple of
minutes explaining
the immune system and antibodies and
what we had to do
but to be less personal and and to
a larger extent i think the life science
sector
has been shown into another
light with the public and we saw
scientists um rise to the occasion
and be really leaders in our societies
in
every country and i think that's
that's a great news um that's that's
great for it for us
um but definitely it we have to be
now very cautious very prudent
um we've seen what accelerated research
can do the good side
but also some of the the bad side
publishing very early on
uh taking every single study as
as as facts
it has some advantages but we need to
make sure the quality of the research
is uh to the the standards that we
usually have um to go forward
but definitely it's it's been it's been
an interesting time
um hopefully we'll come wiser
and and more together than we were
before
but we still have a lot of work to do
thank you fred and also thank you
patricia and jeff all of you for this
informative
discussion we will now start the live q
a
portion of the webinar and just a
reminder to our audience members
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so our first
question
coming in is for you patricia for
sorting of
nuclei for coded 19th study
should the process sample be treated as
bsl1 or bsl2
well thanks for the question nuclei are
typically pretty straightforward
and on an average day we treat them
as dsl1 now for samples coming through
that are
covet positive infected you might want
to take some extra precautions
and sort them as a bsl2
just that abundance of caution but you
know it's more important of how you're
dissociating the samples because
to isolate the nuclei you often have to
use ultracentrifugation which
can be very hazardous if you're using
you know higher biosafety level samples
and so
wherever you're getting the samples from
you should use the appropriate biosafety
level lab to isolate the nuclei and then
once you have the isolated nuclei
i think you know for our purposes it
would be fine to sort those nuclei
and a biosafety level to um so a sorter
that's inside of a biosafety cabinet
so yeah
thank you patricia and this next
question is for you fred
are there any advantages or
disadvantages
possibly in screening covid19 antibodies
using
phase display versus using b cells
that's actually a very good question and
the the main answer is that
both approach have benefits and
shortcoming
we preferred the b cell screening
approach for
covet 19 not because the fake display we
weren't confident
in getting good antibodies from the page
display
but in terms of timing um the visa
screening was
a little shorter uh we were saving maybe
one or two weeks so that's not a lot but
in this crisis uh two weeks is a lot of
time
um but if i answer more generally
um we typically uh we sometimes do
both for for a single program so
definitely there's
there's advantages and good antibodies
usually show up in both
approaches but let's say we are
doing a program to find antagonist
antibodies against
a gpcr in oncology would
probably uh prefer a vsat screening
approach with a spec
with a functionality essay whereas uh we
have done
uh very difficult programs where we know
the immune response is
is very slight there's not a lot of of
good antibodies
and one example i have in mind is we did
an rna
antibody so basically an antibody that
could recognize sequence specifically
um a small rna and you can expect from
from that example that there's not a lot
of immune response against
nucleic acids so in that case we use
phage display because we're looking
we needed to enrich and to find these
rare binders
and that's where the the face display
platform is so powerful
so basically in both cases we would
probably have found
very good antibodies using either phase
display or b-cell screening but
we took b-sub-speeding because we're
saving two weeks
thank you fred and i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
coming in we have time for one more and
we'll turn to you jeff
based on your experience so far can you
comment on what type of flow
cytometry assays are useful to monitor
the efficacy
of an antiviral therapy against covid19
this is a great question um
so i think right now uh there is no
great biomarker that would define uh
a optimal therapy whether that's a
vaccine or
a drug that would stop the virus
and so in light of that what i'm seeing
is people sort of going down two roads
one is
looking at antigen-specific t cell
responses
um using cytokine flow cytometry to look
at cd4 and cd8 t cell responses to the
peptides
from stars cov2 and asking how many
cytokines those
anagen specific t cells produce how
broad
is that response meaning how many
different peptides
are being recognized uh and then i think
on the other side
is the immunophenotyping and this is
looking
at activation markers the frequency of
different immune cell subsets
that are present in patients who
respond better to the vaccines or
produce a broader
or larger number of antigen specific t
cells
or who suppress the virus more quickly
on an antiviral therapy
and looking at those markers of immune
activation
looking at the maturity of the t cells
and the b cells
and probably we need to spend some time
looking at the the myeloid compartment
and then k
cells too to understand what their role
is in fighting this infection
but all of this really is aimed at
high parameter flow cytometry so whether
that's
doing something on a on a scytof or um
or
traditional flow cytometry with
fluorescent markers
um pretty much everybody seems to be
going the route of high parameters so
we're
we're in the process of making a 26
color
or actually pretty far along now and
making a 26 color
um cytokine photo cytometry panel to
look at
antigen specific responses and then we
have a 35 color
panel that we're using to look at
maturation and activation
of the various different immune cell
subsets so we can look at t cells b
cells nk
cells and myeloids um in a single panel
and a lot of this is is really aimed at
screening
patients and then understanding their
disease trajectory
or their vaccine response
after one week one month three months
figure out how long these
responses remain and to what
magnitude they reach
thank you jess and i want to thank each
of you again dr
fred the duke dr jeff millish patricia
rogers for your participation today and
your contributions to the scientific
community
and i also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor sony
biotechnology for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i also want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
levers will alert you via email when it
is available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care be safe bye